row row row your boat don't roll my boat
don't row somebody else's boat don't try
to row a boat that somebody else tells
you you should be rowing and how do you
row this boat always gently always with
peace always with kindness grow your
boat that way row your boat gently down
the stream the road put it this way he
said our truest life is when we are in
our dreams awake because life is but a
dream let's sing it together just for a
minute together ready
row row row your boat gently down the
stream
merrily merrily merrily merrily
that's all it is it's just a dream hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
struggle to believe in myself I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how to change our lives with Wayne Dyer
enjoy
rule number two is follow your calling
you talk about uh when you're a kid you
kind of know what you want to do you can
feel it and if you kind of get away from
that I think you are you become
miserable absolutely and there's a
calling and we all get called and when
you know I'll tell you when you know the
calling is your Dharma it's when you
feel the passion when it's so when it's
something that can't stop you like I
mentioned earlier I'm going to write a
book I was with Arthur Miller years ago
the great uh playwright American
playwright you know a Death of a
Salesman and so on and they ask him at
the age of 91 are you working on another
play and he said I loved his answer he
said I don't know he said but I probably
am yeah and so like he had this kind of
awareness I know exactly what he's
talking about it's like I was called the
father of motivation but motivation is
an ego concept I am going to make it
happen I am motivated spirit is
something very different inspiration
isn't when an idea gets a when you get a
hold of an idea and take get where you
want to go inspiration is when an idea
gets a hold of you which is what your
life is and you allow yourself to be
taken where you were intended to go in
the first place and I think your mom was
absolutely right when she said you will
meet him she she had her absolute
knowing and she probably is behind this
interview here right now because I
wasn't even going to come here I was
going to go back to Maui and then I said
no I'll just instead of flying all the
way back I'll spend a couple of weeks
down here in South Florida my son is
here my daughters are here and so on and
I was back and forth back and forth but
the back and forthness is not something
that you're doing yourself it's like
it's just saying come here you got this
guy he wants to talk to you your mother
probably is right here in the room right
now orchestrating the whole thing and if
there's any book that you want to read
if you don't read another book in the
rest of your life I want you to read
this book I'll send you a copy it's
called dying to be me okay it's the
story of a woman who was going in who
was in a coma and was dying and was
there to give her last breath she had
end-stage cancer answer and she had a
near-death experience and came back and
it's like it'll blow you away it's uh
yes and you'll reconnect with your mom
in the same way rule number three is
live in harmony in the universe
there is an unmeasurable
Indescribable Force
which those who live of the source in
quotes of the source and of the source
means sorcerer
now not sorcerer in the word uh when we
think of sorcerer we think of witches
and incantations and all kinds of Hocus
Pocus and so on that's not what the word
sorcerer means it means of the source
those who live of the source in the
universe there is an unmeasurable and
Indescribable Force which those who live
of the source
call intention
and that absolutely everything that
exists in the entire Cosmos
is attached to intent
by a connecting link
and then he goes on to say Sorcerers are
not only concerned with understanding
and explaining that connecting link
but they are especially concerned
with cleansing it
of the numbing effects brought about
by all of the concerns of living at
ordinary levels of consciousness
very important and powerful words to
consider think of it like this that
everything in this universe was intended
here
including you
including every mosquito and every palm
tree and every avocado and all of the
Rocky Mountains and the oceans that
everything that shows up in the material
world emanates from a source
and this Source can be thought of as
that which intends things into the
material world
and the question here today isn't
whether or not you are going to be
connected to it because you couldn't be
you couldn't be listening to this
program you couldn't be processing what
I'm saying here if you weren't connected
to this field this field beats your
heart
this this field of energy grows your
fingernails and grows everybody else's
fingernails I used to say it uh it grows
your hair but I've become a little
suspicious of that you know
but this
that intention is what I'd like you to
think of when I think about the power of
intention intention isn't about whether
you're going to connect to it you're
already connected to it the question is
how Rusty how corroded how dirty is the
link between you and this field of
intention and
Sorcerers are those who are concerned
with cleansing this connecting link so
that you become more and more in rapport
with or in harmony with this field of
intention and the more you're in harmony
with this field of intention
the more you are able to do all that
this field of intention is able to do
you are able to create Miracles you are
able to heal yourself you are able to
attract into your life the abundance
that has been missing you are able to
find the right people and have them show
up exactly on time because that's how
the universal Source from which all
things and all people originated that's
how it works and what we're going to be
doing here today in this program is
looking at how to get that link back to
intention and to not only be connected
to it
but to always be ready to keep that
connecting link
clean uncorroded
one of the things that really intrigues
me is this idea
and I heard it many many years ago I'm
not even sure of the original Source
where I heard it but it goes like this
when you change
the way you look at things
the things you look at change
Albert Einstein once observed that you
have the most fundamental and major
decision that you have to make in your
life
is this
do I live
in a friendly
or a hostile universe
which is it is it a universe that is
filled with hostility and anger and
people wanting to hate each other and
people wanting to kill each other is
that what you see because when you see
the world that way that's exactly what
you will create for yourself in your
life this is from great scientific minds
and the interesting thing is that this
is not just a a clever play on words
that when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
it's actually a very scientific thing
and I'm going to show you that in just a
moment
I'd like you to imagine the following
scene
you're in your house
you've got your car keys in your hand
the lights go out power failure
you can't see a thing
you stumble around in your living room
and you drop your keys
and you look around for a moment and you
realize that you're never going to find
them in the dark
but you look outside
and you notice that the street lights
are on
so in your mind a light bulb goes off
I'm not going to sit around here in the
dark and grope around looking for my
keys when there's a light on outside I'm
going to go out here
under the street light
and I'm going to look for my keys
why are you laughing this this makes a
lot of sense so you're out here and
you're groping around and you're looking
for your keys and you're looking and
looking and your neighbor comes along
and says what happened Wayne well um I
dropped my keys oh I'll help you look
for them
and the two of us are now down here
looking for our keys and looking finally
he says to me excuse me but
um where did you drop your keys
well um I dropped him in the house
he said you mean to tell me that you
dropped your keys in the house and
you're looking for them out here in the
street light doesn't make any sense and
I said well it doesn't make any sense to
grope around in the dark when there's
light out here
now you laugh and you think how silly
that is but isn't that exactly what we
do when we have a problem a difficulty a
struggle that is located inside
and we're looking for the solution
outside
some place outside of ourselves the
question isn't whether I'm connected to
this field
of intention the question is
how ready am I to keep that connecting
link absolutely corrosion free also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is being
instrument of Peace Way Back 800 years
ago there lived a little man who gave up
all of his possessions
he lived in a little village in uh in
Italy near Florence
called Assisi
and we named one of our most famous
cities in America after him his name was
Francesco
or has he became known later after his
passing
Saint Francis of Assisi
and I went to Assisi and I had miracles
that took place for me in visiting
Assisi on several occasions
and Saint Francis was one of these
people who created a prayer that is
perhaps the most uh well-known prayer uh
on the planet today certainly one of
them
and when I wrote a spiritual solution to
every problem I took the first seven
lines
of this famous prayer
and I made them
into a chapter
of the book and I'd like to share those
with you here in this program right now
those seven lines because they represent
an 800 year old technology if you will
for bringing a spiritual solution to
anything in your life that constitutes a
problem
the first line in this famous prayer
says Lord make me an instrument of thy
peace
how can I become an instrument of thy
the ego is the part of us that wants to
be at war that wants to defeat that
wants to collect that wants to be better
than that wants to always get more
the sacred or the highest part of
ourselves is the part of us that just
wants to be at peace how can I become an
instrument of Peace not someone who's
looking for peace but someone who
delivers it there are opportunities
every day I was in a gas station just a
few days ago and in this gas station
they had a car wash and there was a
young boy he was maybe 18 or 19 years
old and he didn't speak English very
well and he couldn't figure out how to
work the car wash and he had put two
dollars in and apparently it required
three dollars and he was in there
waiting to uh pay for his uh his car
wash and trying to get an answer to why
he couldn't get it to work and I had
just gotten some gasoline and I walked
in and there was this man behind the
counter berating this young boy and
humiliating him and talking to him and
because he didn't understand the
language he talked louder to him you
know how people do that you know if if
someone doesn't understand you you say
what I said is and they say I don't
understand and then you say it even
louder
um well that's what they were he was
doing to this young boy and he was and I
saw this is an opportunity right here in
this instant to be an instrument of
peace and I put my arm around the young
man and I said come with me and I walked
out to the machine and I took a dollar
and I put it in them and he walked away
and he was just so happy one tiny little
incident these kinds of things I suggest
to you that you take this day and look
for five occasions to be an instrument
of peace and you'll find one when you're
on your way home on the freeway you'll
find somebody who isn't going to let you
get in you find somebody who doesn't
want to let you pass and instead of uh
you know giving them a hard time or
being angry at them try sending
something called peace their way
there's a wonderful line that I have on
the dashboard of my car it says I can
choose peace
rather than this
and it's always a reminder that no
matter how I'm experienced what I'm
experiencing in my life I want to be an
instrument of peace
the second line in this very famous
prayer says where there is hatred
let me sow love
it's been said that the three most
difficult things to do in the world
are this the first is to send love in
response to hatred
the second is to defend the absent
that is whoever's being gossiped about
you become their spokesperson I do this
with my children all the time when
they're all saying this and then she
said that he said excuse me but who is
defending the absent person here wow why
should anybody defend her I'll say well
I'll just take her position right now if
you don't mind
the third is to admit
admit and it doesn't mean necessarily to
say I just made a mistake it means to
say
I have been making the wrong kinds of
choices in my life with my mind I've
been putting my attention on what I
don't want on what others want for me on
what the world ought to be on what it
used to be and I can't understand why it
just keeps showing up what I don't want
what others want from me what I despise
I have to admit almost I have to rewrite
my agreement with reality rule number
five is believe that all things are
possible the ego and awareness cannot
coexist together the ego is
a kind of thinking that says that who I
am is what I have and what I do and what
other people think of me and that I'm
separate from everyone else and I'm
separate from God and and I evaluate
myself on the basis of this and many of
you grew up with this idea that uh who
you are is what you do what you
accumulate what other people think of
you your reputation and so on thinking
with awareness is thinking from the
highest place that there is it's the
kind of thinking that allows excuses to
be eradicated from your life
it's the thinking that uh
is talked about in the New Testament
with God
all things
are possible
now you tell me what does that leave out
what is all things are possible leave
out
nothing does it so when you think from a
place of awareness
you think in terms of instead of using
one of these excuses that you see
popping up here on these little thought
bubbles across the stage I can't do it
I'm too tired I'm too old it's going to
be difficult it's going to take a long
time which is all the ego stuff which
promotes these mind viruses and these
memes instead of that when you think
with awareness your first thought is no
matter what it is if you get a cold you
know if you get you know if you hurt
yourself in some way your first thought
isn't oh this is something I can't do
anything about and I'm going to be
hobbled and and I'm going your first
thought is
With God all things are possible with
Source all things are possible
it doesn't mean that you're instantly
healed and the cold is going to go away
but you set your mind on a new way of
looking at virtually anything that comes
into your life all things are possible
and getting to that place in your life
is it's one of the most beautiful things
that you can experience and I try to
practice this over and over and again
whatever it might be whether it's a
family crisis what's a financial crisis
whatever it may be instead of saying
that with the economy and it's going to
turn down and terrible things are going
to happen and I'm going to lose my job
you know you instantly you have a
thought an affirmation within you that
says I can handle this I am not alone I
can make myself get through this uh I
have the solution is going to be out
there I may not know what it is but my
thoughts are always on it's possible and
rule number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is stop seeking
approval the funny part about approval
for those of you who really want it and
re now I'm here to tell you that I like
approval I enjoy it I find it one of the
most exciting things in the world I like
it when people read my books I love it
when people applaud I like it when
people uh tell me nice things and all I
like approval I'm the first one to admit
it what I don't do is I don't need
approval there's a big difference
between wanting approval and needing
approval when you need approval it means
you become immobilized when you don't
get it
from making other people's opinions more
important now for those of you who say
yeah but I want approval and I need it
and if I don't get it and so on then
understand this the people who get the
most approval in life
are the ones who care the least about it
and the ones who get the least approval
are the ones who are always going after
it so if you want approval in this
paradoxical way that I'm talking about
it
stop needing it
stop concerning yourself about ask
yourself who gets the most approval in
life
think of the person that gets the most
approval and you'll see that that person
couldn't care less what other people are
thinking
they're so busy being they don't have
time to notice what their neighbors are
doing hero said this he said if you
advance confidently
in the direction of your own dreams
and Endeavor to live the life
which you have imagined
you will meet with a success
unexpected in common hours
what that means is that success is not
something that you can get in life
success is an inner process
success is something that you bring to
everything you do in your life it isn't
something you get out of what you do
and when you get that and you learn how
to get the junk out and Advance
confidently doing what makes the most
amount of sense to you based on your
inner signals and the one issue of
morality which is you never interfere
with anybody else's right to do the same
each person has their own right to
advance confidently in the direction of
their own dreams
and when you violate that you're
violating the principle of the universe
the essence of the universe
is cooperation and harmony
then success will begin to chase you and
it will come into your life and arrive
in your life in amounts that you never
dreamed of before
humans are built to serve if you are not
happy it's because you do not feel like
you are serving people if you wake up
and you're not happy you feel like today
doesn't matter today doesn't count
nobody cares if you show up or not
that's the path down to anxiety and
stress and depression and suicide
because you feel like you don't belong
because it feels like
you can spend all day working on
something and nobody's gonna care
that's the feeling that nobody wants
right you don't want to wake up and feel
like you're going to spend all day today
and nobody will care
how do you get people to Care by serving
by helping we all want to wake up and
feel like today is gonna count it's
gonna mean something to somebody and
maybe today is the big day that you get
that big news or the big deal or the big
contract or the big subscriber goal or
whatever your goals are maybe it's that
day
but those goals aren't enough
how many times have you hit a goal and
realized oh that's it right you feel
great have that happen if you like oh I
got a million subscribers and then then
what what does that mean
and it's off to the next goal if you're
just living for little sugar highs
you're not having happiness at the
foundational level in your life
because you don't feel like you're
serving
we have to tie the work that we do into
feeling like today is going to mean
something if you woke up today and felt
like today was going to mean something
today was gonna matter
that I'm gonna put something out into
the world I'm gonna make this YouTube
video I'm just sitting here in my office
or standing on my trampoline in my
office that I'm gonna make something
today that will matter that will touch
somebody if I felt that
I'm gonna show up totally differently
than like whatever another video okay
who cares
you know required hey Evan yeah yeah
next right you just show up differently
based off your feeling about yourself
that you're doing something that's going
to serve people
so if you're struggling with that and
you're you're coming up with your list
of goals and you've got your dream board
and you've got your Lamborghini and your
vacation home and the airplane and a
fancy hotel those are not the things
that will make you happy those are not
your real goals
that's a fake dream board
the thing that will make you sustainably
happy is feeling like you're serving
and the next level of it is either
serving more deeply or more broadly
you take the people who are closest to
you and you really focus on helping them
and help improve their lives in a
significant way or you're going to reach
a lot more people
but if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving
so how do you do it how do you how do
you serve at a higher level and give you
three quick ideas that I think will help
number one
there's a process I go through it's
called who I how so number one is your
who your who is your single most
important core value what is your single
most important core value I write about
this and build the serve you can go
check it out if you want your single
most important core value what is it
for me it's belief
for you maybe it's believed too but
maybe a good chance that it's something
else but your single most important core
value
as you go through it I found that it's
funny how everybody's core value is
something positive this is why I believe
people are good
because I've never had somebody's core
value come back as hate or death or be
toxic right never it's always something
aspirational positive which means that
people are good we do things that we're
not proud of we sometimes are negative
to others because we're in a lot of pain
at that moment but deep down at a core
level humans are good so you figure out
your single most important core value
what is it don't worry about being
perfect just even right now what comes
to mind what what single word is really
important to you right now a core value
great
how you can serve
is to bring more of that to yourself and
then to bring more of that to other
people
the ultimate service for me is believing
more in myself so then I can believe
more in other people as well the goal of
making these videos is to help you
believe in yourself more to help the
world believe in themselves more to
unlock the Michael Jordan level genius
that we all have inside of us that
you're the best in the world that's
something what is it I don't know I hope
you do but if not let's Discover it and
send it out to the world
your ultimate happiness satisfaction Joy
fulfillment will yes come from serving
other people but in for me believing in
them if I could help even through this
video or conversation or a clubhouse or
a live session
if I knew that I was going to say
something that would help even one
person on the call believing themselves
a little bit more
mission accomplished
so adding Clarity you know you want to
serve you know if you're not happy
you're not serving great
how the first level of clarity is you're
who your single most important core
value figure out what that is even if
you have a starting point or being
perfect
the more that you can help yourself and
others believe that thing the more happy
you will be
next level down is your why so Point
number two is your why your why is your
purpose and your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggled the most
with is the thing you want to help other
people through it's great to hold the
door for somebody or buy the coffee
behind in line or or buy somebody a
balloon or give a sandwich to somebody
who's you know hungry like all those
things are great it's great these
momentary acts of kindness are fantastic
amazing do more of them what will fill
you up on an even deeper level is
recognizing that your ultimate purpose
your why
comes from helping people who currently
are who you used to be
go back to the moment in your life where
you felt the the lowest the loneliness
the least uh the least level of
confidence you've ever had in yourself
when did you feel worthless as a human
what was that moment
hopefully it's not right now it's
probably not right now if you're
watching these videos because you're
you're on your way up
go back to when you would never watch
one of these videos go back to when it
was just the worst day of your life when
was that for you you've come through
you're not done you're not done climbing
growing learning getting better you're
still a long way from where you want to
be and that's amazing
and you're way further than you used to
be
your why your purpose is to help the
people who currently are who you used to
be
they'll look to you and see
guidance hope encouragement support
inspiration motivation
because you're ahead
of where they are right now
the you from five years ago would look
to you and be inspired right the the
Advent from five years ago from 10 years
ago you look at 10 years 10 years ago on
YouTube I had I don't know 100
subscribers
he's trying to make 10-year goals I
would never predict that I'd be here 10
years ago Evan is looking to Adventures
like you did all that oh my gosh it's
crazy we never Pat ourselves on the back
and give ourselves enough credit for
those things
and there are millions of people right
now who are struggling with the same
thing
whatever you struggled with
there are millions of people who are
struggling with that same thing right
now and they need you they need your
voice they need your help they need
support they need your guidance they
need your encouragement they need your
words they need you they need you and
helping those people will feel
so much better than just doing a random
act of kindness It's just levels of
service right random back behind this
great little candy but deep fulfillment
will be from helping the people who
currently are who you used to be that's
your why that's your purpose it will
never get old you'll love doing that for
the rest of your life
and then step number three is the how
the how is how did you get out of the
hole you were in what were the steps
that you took so for me getting out of
the hole that I was in where the worst
day of my life was quitting on my
business partner in my first company
how to get out of the hole while I
modeled success
and I tried a million different things
you know and modeling success was just a
a desperation play you know like okay oh
my gosh I don't know what else to do who
else has done this so Bill Gates started
a software company what did he do I felt
like I was grasping a straw it's like I
had no idea what I was doing
it was just an idea that came the man
was willing to try anything at that
point because the other alternative was
just to quit on my company and go find a
job
now luckily that was the one that
actually ended up working out
and now anytime when I don't know what
to do something I try to model success
like who's done this thing and how can I
learn from them instead of having to
reinvent the wheel every time
and so what have I done for the past
20 years oh my gosh 20 years what have I
done for the past 20 years
teach people how they can model success
too
right
the how matters how you got out of the
hole that you were in you can then teach
other people what worked for you you
tried all these things that didn't work
and you almost gave up and then you
found something that did kind of work
and then you worked on it and you
improved it and you refined it that is
now teachable to other people
show them the process to get out of the
hole
because they don't see any help and they
think they're stuck for life
in your story your message will help
pull them out in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't in a way that Lisa
Nichols can't and the way that Tony
Robbins canons in a way that anybody can
but you can because you are exactly
the person that they need to hear from
because you've gone through exactly the
problem that they are struggling with
you're who you're why you're how it's
all been built to surf
that's your path
if you're not happy
it's because you're not serving you feel
like today doesn't matter it doesn't
mean anything to anybody else
and you flip that
just by reminding yourself
of Who You Are
of why you do what you do
and how you got out of the hole so you
can feel like today will mean something
to somebody else and then if you keep
showing up consistently every day and
putting in the work the impact that you
will have on this planet
will inspire you
to a level that you can't even imagine
right now
you are built to serve you can't give
away
what you don't have
now it sounds ridiculous okay but it's
more than what meets the ear as you hear
this you can't give away what you don't
have
people who are not good at giving away
love can't give away love because they
don't have it to give away if I want to
give you a dozen oranges
I can't give you those dozen oranges
unless I go out and pick up 12 oranges
someplace
otherwise all it is is just empty
rhetoric
and the same thing is true of virtually
everything in your life you can't give
away love for others if you don't have
love in here to give away if what you
have in here is contempt if what you
have in here is anger if what you have
in here is fear then these are the
things you're going to be giving away in
your life
and I've often thought and I really
believe very strongly that there's a law
sort of a law in the universe I call it
the law of attraction
and the law of attraction is one that
works like this
you get back from the universe from the
world what it is that you put out there
in the world
and if you're putting out there into the
world that I am not worthy of attracting
Something Beautiful into my life that
the universe will respond back to you
with exactly that message
and there are people who come to me and
who came to me for years when I had my
own counseling practice and so on and
they would say to me
um I just keep attracting the same kind
of people the same kind of events the
same kind of uh losers into my life why
is that why do I keep doing it and I
keep attracting uh an absence of uh of
abundance I just can't seem to attract
abundance into my life I'm always behind
the eight ball I'm never getting ahead
and I suggested them I said did it ever
occur to you that that's the very kind
of message you're sending out to the
world and out to the universe that the
ocean of abundance is there and you can
go to that ocean of abundance
and you can take a Mac Truck
and you can fill it up 20 times a day
and take it out of there and guess what
it doesn't impact at all
the ocean of abundance it doesn't even
go down a zillionth of an inch it's
unlimited or you can go to the same
ocean of abundance with a eyedropper
and you can just take this much out once
a month and say that's all that seems to
be available for me
and the interesting thing for me is that
when people go to this ocean of
abundance this unlimited World all that
I have is thine it says in the Holy
books all that I have is thine it's all
there for you but if you believe inside
that it's limited that you can only get
so much
that other people are going to get it
before you do then you'll find yourself
creating that very same thing and the
even more interesting part about this
you can't give away what you don't have
principle
is that if your message to the universe
is gimme gimme gimme which is a lot of
people's message to the universe I want
this from you I want that from you
please give me this I have to have that
that's what their prayer is like that's
what their message is you know and they
say I want this from the universe give
me give me give me
the universe's response back to that
kind of a mentality is exactly the same
the universe will say right back to you
over and over again give me hear me
give me and you'll find yourself never
ever arriving but always being in a
state of striving always feeling as if
you're being neglected never feeling as
if you have enough always feeling as if
you're being shortchanged because you're
constantly under the pressure to give to
get back what the universe is demanding
from you and the interesting thing about
all of this the the irony of this is
that if you shift that
and you say
to the universe to the world
how may I serve
the universe's response back to you is
how may I serve you
how may I serve you and it's very
intriguing when you take your energy and
your attention off of what you are
demanding from the world and instead
saying what can I give to the world
and it's really the the basis behind
that very famous line of the President
John Kennedy's inaugural address ask not
what your country can ask what you can
do for your country and the irony of
that is and I've learned that in my own
life that when I stop thinking about
what was in it for Wayne Dyer and how
much could I get and I began to shift
and say how can I help you how can I
give to you what can I do for you and
people who write to me I send them
something when when I encounter somebody
that needs help of some kind I'm very
often just giving that to them and then
I find that it just keeps coming back
into my life and once I shifted that
energy off of what can I have into what
can I give it seemed to me that the
Universe responded back with the very
same message what can I give to you and
the most incredible and wonderful and
beautiful abundance has flowed into my
life in every way that I can possibly
think of
you can't give away what you don't have
there are no Justified resentments
and this is a very difficult principle
for many people to get but one that I
believe very strongly in
I was in a group one time
of uh drug addicts and alcoholics
[Music]
and I was one of the people that was a
sponsor and leading this group
and the sign on the wall said there are
no Justified resentments in this group
and
what I said to that group that that
night was no matter what anybody says to
you here no matter what kind of uh uh
anger comes directed towards you no
matter how much hate you may encounter
showing up in your life there are no
Justified
resentments meaning that if you carry
around resentment inside of you about
anything or about anyone and I'm talking
about the person that you lent money to
and hasn't paid you back I'm talking
about the person in your life that you
feel was abusive in your life I'm
talking about the person who walked out
on you and left you for somebody else
I'm talking about all of the things that
you have justified in your heart and in
your life that you have the right to be
resentful about and I'm suggesting to
you that those resentments will always
end up
harming you and creating in you a sense
of Despair I've often said that you no
one ever dies from a snake bite
the snake bite will never kill you you
cannot be unbitten once you're bitten
you're bitten
but it's the Venom that continues
to pour through your system after the
bite
that will end up destroying you have a
mind that is open to everything
and attached to nothing
one of the central principles of my life
is that no one knows enough
to be a pessimist about anything
and that each and every one of us
when we close our mind to what is
possible for us or what is possible for
Humanity
closes off the genius
that resides and lives in each and every
one of us
having an open mind doesn't necessarily
mean finding fault with all of the
things that you've been taught by others
it means opening yourself up
to the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible
so having a mind that is open to
everything and attached to nothing
really means finding within ourselves
the ability to get rid of a trait that I
find so common in contemporary
in the Contemporary world
do you know that most people that I meet
spend their lives
looking
for occasions
to be offended
they actually are out there hoping that
they can find some reason to be offended
and there's no shortage of reasons
they're out there everywhere the way
this person dressed the what the worst
person said they turn on the TV they
hear the news they're offended by this
someone didn't someone used language
that they didn't like someone doesn't
share the same Customs at you and people
all day long in fact if you keep track
tomorrow you will find
uh probably a hundred reasons that you
can go around being offended but a mind
that is open to everything and attached
to nothing is a mind that says I'm never
looking for anything to be offended by
and that whatever anybody else out there
has to say my response to that is
that's an interesting point of view
I've never considered that before the
next principle I call don't die with
your music Still In You
[Music]
and who better to quote than Thoreau
right here in Concord
when he talked about some of us hear A
Different Drummer
and we must March to the music that we
hear
but all of you everybody watching
everybody here in this beautiful Parish
all of you have some music playing
and all of you have a heroic mission
there's no accidents in this universe we
all show up here
with a purpose
there's an intelligence that is a part
of everything and everyone and all of us
are connected to it
and too many of us
are afraid to listen to that music and
March to it
you out there
I know you have a book you wanted to
write
I know there's a composition you wanted
to compose I know there's a song you
want to sing someplace maybe you want to
raise horses out in Montana
or maybe you want to open up an ice
cream shop on Cape Cod who knows what it
may be maybe you just want to travel and
see the world maybe you want to go into
a relationship with someone but you've
been afraid to but your heart says it's
the right thing to do
all of us feel something
and in Leo tolstoy's famous novel The
Death of Ivan Ilitch
he asked this question
that would be terrifying to me
he says as he has his accountant from
Moscow lying on his deathbed
contemplating the horror of this
question
what if my whole life
has been wrong
[Music]
I've known what my music is
playing right now
because I stand here in front of you
with these cameras and in this place
as I sit down and write my books and
tell the world what I know are my truths
I feel always completely on purpose and
fulfilled and no time will I ever come
to the end of my life and say what if my
whole life has been wrong
whoever you are whatever that music is
however distant it may sound however
strange however weird Others May
interpret it to be
don't get to the end of your life
and know that you're going to leave
and not have it played yet
don't die with your music Still In you
what a spiritual film mean to you and
and what are your most favorite films
about transformation
well aside from Europe yeah yes
um I love uh you know one of my very
favorite movies was just recently a a
spiritual Cinema a monthly selection
whatever it was it was called Deja Vu
yes with Vanessa Redgrave yeah that that
film just blew me away yeah I mean
you know any film that has Chase scenes
in it or has violence in it or guns
entered and so on I'm just I don't
really turn off I just I don't even go
to them but um like that film got me
really thinking about the possibilities
if any of you haven't seen the
wonderment of a great film like that is
that you begin to think oh oh there's
this possibility which which yeah that
all you know that all things are
possible and you can make anything
happen do you think that films can be
used for social social change oh
absolutely see one of the reasons I did
it did this film The the shift yeah was
because I and I've heard that uh 10 of
the people in this in our country by
um almost 100 of the book something like
97 98 of the books which means that
approximately 85 to 90 percent of the
people never buy never buy a book and
I've written lots and lots of books but
those those but those same 90 right
those same 90 of the people
um they go to the movies they go they go
to the movies so I thought well I and I
remember because it was brilliantly done
because I remember seeing the promotion
on the internet for months and or maybe
maybe a year prior to to it coming out
it was always it was very intriguing and
well there's just great people in it
Michael version is a great director and
Portia de Rossi I mean and Michael
DeLuise Dom DeLuise yeah all of the
people in this film are when I was asked
to do the film I did the film at the age
of 68 and which meant taking on a whole
new career
um because I don't take Direction well
and I speak like I'm speaking now in
front of an audience I don't use notes
but when you do a film as you know do it
being having been in films you do the
same thing over and over and over and
over again and I just decided that this
was something that I could do I just uh
one of the excuses I didn't want to use
is I'm too old to learn this so you
can't teach an old dog new tricks you
can teach an old dog anything you know
and so uh I'm sure you were still
spontaneous or you know anyway well I
insisted that it be professionally done
and I didn't because I've seen a lot of
this a lot of the movies that are called
spiritual movies but I the quality the
quality is just not there and there's
people trying to be actors and they're
not and so on
um I wanted it to be a polished
professional film good for you and my
goal was to have 10 million people watch
it and I and I know that that will
happen and what will happen once you see
10 million in America is pie if you
remember Pie when you were in Geometry
3.1416 if you can get 3.1416 of a
population to a line all the rest all
the rest fall into place
so for me if 10 million people watch the
shift we can make a shift not only in
our country but on our planet as well
and that's why I'm happy to have the
film as part of spiritual Cinema because
it's another whole bunch of thousands of
people who want to tell us inspired the
whole spiritual Cinema Circle you know
fan base they've they're totally turned
on by the films and that's wonderful
that's great what films you think have
made a positive impact on society
well I remember
what was the the
who was the guy that ran all the way
across the country what was uh oh
Forrest Gump Forrest Gump Forrest Gump
was one of those kind of films that made
people look at uh
at people who we call special needs and
and see the beauty and see the the joy
in them
um I think the film about uh that what
Tom Hanks was in uh about the D-Day
um oh yeah Saving Private Ryan yes I
think that that film transformed my
brother's life my brother Dave was in
Vietnam was a bronze star winner and saw
saw such horrible horrible violence he
was a medic there and he saw hundreds
and hundreds of people and he had never
talked about it for um for 30 40 years
never talked about it he was just so
bogged up inside you couldn't get a word
out of him he now has Parkinson's
disease and
um so many those people of that
generation weren't allowed to really
speak about you know and he said yeah
that's what it's like yeah that's what
it's like I think the film ghost was uh
it was one of those films that really
you know deeply and profoundly uh
touched me in in terms of looking at
um when it opened that window yeah
guidance from the other side yeah those
kinds of things yeah lots more lots more
yeah
so what kind of films do you think young
people should see and why
well I think young people should see
films that um
I don't like to use the word should but
I I yeah but I think young people
um Can can benefit greatly by uh
by films that that give them sort of an
expanded view of of what is possible in
the world instead of so much of what we
think young people want to see which is
you know a lot of silliness and a lot of
violence yeah and and a lot of obscenity
and so on
um too and also empty you know these
empty films it's like there's so much
big something happening but there's no
you know you cut you look under the
surface and there's nothing going on I
get letters from people who've seen the
shift
um and they said they just had it on in
their home and the you know their
teenagers will come in and they'll say
what are you watching and all this is
not and then before you know it they're
they're hooked yeah they're hooked and
they're watching and they're telling
other people about it as well so
um I think I think if it can just expand
your Consciousness and just and I think
film can can make a huge difference in
in transforming the world I really do
yeah well you've kind of answered this
question and you've sort of made this
film but I'm going to ask it anyway if
time money or Talent or an obstacle what
kind of movie would you like to make if
you've got got to do it again
and you had every everything at your
disposal now having made a film I you
know the opportunity that is there was
there were no obstacles the money wasn't
an obstacle and time wasn't and I kind
of thought I just did we just did what
we wanted to do and um and I think this
film and maybe perhaps a follow-up to it
maybe following the characters or
something
um this uh
I would just like to make a film that
can can make make the shift because
we've got to we've got to make the shift
well this has been just delightful I
could speak to you forever but I think
we've run out of time thank you so much
I was such a admirer of your grandfather
oh thank you such a bad Mark why I say
thank you because I'm responsible well I
remember reading Islands in the Stream
yeah and a lot of people uh you know one
of the lines that he had in there a man
had just been uh he just found out that
his son had been killed in the in the
war in uh in in Spain
um and he that night was out dancing
and someone said to him how can you be
dancing when you've just found out that
news and I've never forgotten this he
said he said I decided that sooner or
later I would have to get over this or
it would kill me and he said I just
picked sooner and I learned that from
your grandfather Yeah
Yeah most people are victims because of
choice or because of expectations people
expect to be victimized they think
they think they're not very strong and
they're not very capable or they they
don't have very high aspirations that's
if there's anything that I think people
suffer from in this country it's that
not that they fail to achieve so much is
that they fail to Aspire they don't have
a sense of their own internal capacities
and greatness or abilities to handle
just about any situation well we've
talked about that before but how can a
book tell you how to do this well a book
can't do it for you I'm the first one
absolutely just like going to a
psychiatrist a psychiatrist cannot make
your life any better I'm convinced of
that nor can a valium or anything like
that it has to be something that you do
internally yourself it can provide your
guidelines it's very much like if you
your car breaks down and you got your
repair manual there you say well why
isn't this manual fixing my car manuals
don't fix cars they can just give you
the information you either do it to
yourself or you don't but can the book
give you a way to rate yourself as far
as what how how victimized you you
really are yeah I I think so uh a lot of
people are very critical of books and
self-help books and whether or not they
can really be helpful to people and so
on and I know in my own life I've been
really influenced by some very
significant writing of people who've
lived before me a lot of poets uh a lot
of the great you know even Mark Twain
reading people books have really
influenced my life these kinds of books
influence people's lives today I know it
from the mail that I get and uh well
what's step one
you've read the book step one is to
change your expectations around like
every situation you go into all right
you got who victimizes people the most
in our culture family members you know
uh your parents telling you that you
ought to be the way they want you to be
your uh your children telling you that
they expect you to make their lunches
for them they expect you to pick after
the up after them and so on uh
bureaucrats our government uh clerks
people like that waiters tipping when
you're getting bad service all of these
kinds of things you just change around
your expectations you say I am not going
to allow this person or this institution
to get me I'm not going to try to change
it for the whole world but Wayne How to
specifically I feel sorry for mothers
who are victimized every day I mean by
husbands and by kids you know they have
no they have no self left they give
everything and they but they've taught
themselves that they said to their
husbands or their children uh it's okay
you can push me around if you want to
get uh angry at me or upset at me then
I'll take that and I believe you get
treated in life the way you teach people
to treat you if you've taught people
that you're going to be a dish rag or
you're going to be somebody who's going
to clean up all the time and you're not
going to have any esteem for yourself
then naturally people are going to come
along and just do that but it's a desire
to be approved to be loved so now you're
saying No More Mr Nice Guy I don't think
people are loved I think it's a myth
that you that you love dish Rags or that
you love people I I think people respect
strength not weakness and you stand up
to somebody you said say what's really
on your mind and that first people will
feign it you know they'll fake it they
say oh my God you've really hurt my
feelings that's a strategy that's a
technique to get you you know if I can
get you to come over and visit me on
Sunday by using guilt you know and
saying oh if you don't visit me you know
it's okay I went through 18 hours of
child labor but that's okay if you don't
come and I can use all of this stuff and
you'll come well I'm going to continue
to use that but if you say wait a second
you know I've got a right to decide
where I'm going to be on Sunday and I'm
I can't be there this Sunday and you're
firm about that you know what happens is
after a while people respect you more
what happens at work though when you go
down and tell that to your boss the very
same thing I'm talking about it you're
fired no no hardly ever and even if you
are it's generally for the better uh
even on the job people respect strength
you don't want somebody on the job who's
always going to be a yes man who's
always going to you know if you're
trying to run the show and you want to
know how things are going and what the
reactions are and you got a lot of yes
men around you which is like what Nixon
had around him everybody's just going
around saying yes sir yes and you find
that the show's ratings are going down
and down and now because people aren't
being willing to be honest with you you
want to have a producer a director or
staff people who are going to say look
this is what you're doing that's not
working this is what's effective you
don't have to be nasty yeah but we
expect that but the question I have is
if you've set a pattern in your
household as a mother or even in a
relationship with a man or vice versa
and you've been the giver and the nice
guy all of a sudden when you make that
change then don't people pull back and
say wait you don't love me anymore yeah
they do and that's a technique too
that's a strategy to get you to go back
to uh being a slave again and when they
when you suddenly say to them I'd love
you has nothing to do with love it has
to do with my interest in being my own
person and you're you're using guilt
saying you know you don't love me isn't
going to work anymore how many women how
many times in your life have you gone
out with a man when you were dating or
if you're dating now uh have somebody
called you up and you know you don't
want to go out with this person you know
you nice guy everything is but you know
there's nothing there and you can't say
no yeah and you just say oh wow and then
there there you are three weeks later
you're going out on a date and you're
and this guy is coming on to you and all
and you just saying what am I doing here
I know and learning how to just say no
you know I don't want to go and he said
well you know you're hurting my feelings
and I'll probably have to put my head in
the oven and you know any numbers all
right all right I'll go I'll go you know
anything you know and this is the you
know that's a victim status you've got
to learn not to make commitments for
things and actually what you're saying
be a little selfish huh selfish not
inconsiderate yes but selfish definitely
in this long time yeah it's your life
it's your time it's the only shot you
get at this life and why should anybody
else run it for you oh it seems like an
awful lot of selfish people in the world
already well selfish when you you
selfish generally you mean inconsiderate
you know stepping on other people not
caring about others I don't believe in
that I don't do that myself I spend most
of my life in the service of other
people but it's because if you love
yourself you can you can give love away
if you if you can't give away what you
don't have if you don't okay that's step
one No More Mr Nice Guy number two
it's like going out and practicing you
know uh really standing up for the
things you know somebody's out there uh
go practice being insulted in fact it's
necessary but but it isn't necessary you
know I have a thing called being quietly
effective John and it's like you know a
lot of people misconstrue their goals in
life they pull into a gas station right
and they want their windshield washed
the guy is too busy he doesn't care he's
not interested he doesn't wash your
windshield this person who wants his
windshield what forgets his goal is just
to have a windshield wash that's all he
now says I'm going to reform that guy
how dare he treat me that way who does
he think and he's gonna and this guy's
behavior is suddenly controlling them
emotionally and your goal is just to
Simply say look would you mind washing
my windshield you don't have to give a
lecture if the guy says look I'm too
busy you say well now I'm going to talk
to the manager or whatever you know you
go on to the next step or you get out
and wash it yourself it's necessary but
you don't allow other people's behavior
to be the controlling thing of your
emotions in your life whether that's
that clerk there or whether it's your
husband or your children
about explanation what about people that
feel like they've got to give a long
drawn out explanation with a thousand
reasons and excuses they become victims
you know and then somebody at the end
you know what they'll say I just don't
understand you I don't know
I better go back and I better start
watching as I'm confident versus cocky I
mean confident versus insulting I mean
is there a fine line you have to learn
relearn that the the very specific line
confident means standing up for what you
believe cocky or abusive or conceited
means trying to convince other people of
how terrific you are if you run your
life on your inner signals you don't
have any need to show anybody else how
great you are if you're confident you
just simply do it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
feel lost and want to change your future
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there number one is
obviously just shifting the perspective
of I need to do more things and I need
to add more things to my routine when in
fact you need to stop doing things that
you're currently doing all that remains
is the work to be done priorities mean
two things